bonjour david pourquoi une telle
décision expliquez nous et bien c'est
une consternation à pour l'ensemble des
aides soignants de ce service à tout
d'abord pour vous rappeler à ce chiffre
à plus de mille patients sont en
réanimation en ile de france et peut
atteindre à tout moment le pic de
saturation est des hôpitaux franciliens
est la raison avancée à par l'ap-hp
c'est d'abord pour redéployer le
personnel de ce service d'urgence mais
aussi à créer plus de lits dans des
hôpitaux voisins en l'occurrence
l'hôpital cochin
c'est une décision contestée car ce
n'est pas un déplacement des urgences
mais c'est un déplacement de personnel
qui est pris en compte
est ce qu'il veut dire qu
automatiquement on ferme des lits au
lieu d'en créer bien on en supprime des
vikings qui existe un délit de
réanimation qui peuvent être utilisés
ici l'aspect vétuste également de
l'hôtel-dieu est remise en cause par
l'ap-hp
une affirmation totalement insensé pour
la plupart des élus qui sont venus
soutenir l est le service d'urgence de
l'hôtel dieu je vous propose de
l'écouter aller visiter les locaux vous
avez des locaux qui ont été complètement
refait à neuf
un plateau technique est tout à fait
opérationnel donc ça c'est une c'est un
mensonge éhonté vous aviez lors du
premier confinement martin hirsch avait
y compris dit qu'il y avait pas de de
fluides or il ya les flux d'oxygène
totalement disponible dans cet hôpital
non pelées mensonges ça suffit on arrête
de casser l'hôpital public on n'accepte
pas la fermeture des urgences nous
venons pour visiter avec la direction
les locaux et pour prouver qu'ils ne
sont absolument pas vétuste et qu'ils
sont tout à fait opérationnel pour
recevoir des patients qui sont non pas
qu'ils n'ont pas obligatoirement besoin
de réanimation un moment donné où il
manque des lits on voit que c'est une
aberration parce qu'ils vont préférer
utiliser des transferts en tgv pour
changer des patients de région plutôt
que d'utiliser cet hôpital qui est prêt
à accueillir les patients
ce que dénonce également les élus c'est
un projet de privatisation
d'un tiers de l'hôtel du centre et la
ville de paris à la fois pour en faire
des logements étudiants et des commerces
mais également un restaurant
gastronomique
malgré elle le confinement une poignée
d'êtres soignants et des lieux sont
venus ici un protesté devant
l'hôtel-dieu la police a rapidement
opéré à des verbalisations et disperser
ce rassemblement pour pouvoir faire
respecter le confinement il en place par
le gouvernement
merci beaucoup d'avis de khalifa depuis
l'hôtel dieu